[Music]
congratulations bar this is Maxim
magazine and there were a hundred women
up for this honor and you come in number
one that must be pretty exciting it's
very exciting
I don't know that can be actually well I
dunno how it can be look at this picture
that's how it can be beautiful gorgeous
yeah and you're you appear to be
completely naked in that photo well you
know I'm not that confident I actually
had a thin line of underwear that they
airbrushed out oh that's how they do it
now yeah so you wear underwear but then
they they airbrush it out exactly when
the model doesn't agree to appear
completely naked then you have to use
the magic of computers right right yeah
that must be so a nerd was sitting at a
computer screen working on that very
lucky nerd yes um I just I'm just
imagining that you are you're on the
number one on this Maxim list and and
long before this I've known about you I
think about you often men must go you've
not responded to any of my letters men
must go to great lengths to meet you do
men are men very forward with you and
they always trying to meet you okay
let's put it let's let's put it out
there no one hits on me no bye guys no
one flirts with me it's like it's the
most yeah it's really sad actually
but why do you think they they don't is
it because they're intimidated you say
would you tell me please what you're
taking the wrong guy because I am
nothing but confidence when I'm around
for that that's just cruel but back in
my single days if I saw you I wouldn't
mince words I would come right towards
you and I would be extremely confident
and I'd be in a office chair with wheels
really not at all what kind of lines do
here what are some of the things that
guys do try when they're when they see
you I had not long ago I had this guy I
was at a club and I was like sitting
like this on my blackberry and I was
really bored I just wanted to go home
and then I see feet I'm like okay I hope
this guy will get away like really soon
and then I hear three one oh five three
three and I look up I'm like what he
goes you want to write down my number
right that's what you're doing I'm like
I'm taken but if I wasn't I would
totally call you that works a guy coming
up to you that confident and saying
here's my number because I know you want
it I mean a guy yeah I got it was up to
me works I hope that will happen every
now and then but I think after this
interview your life is going to change
you just put it out there that no one
speaks to me what is it you look for in
a guy
tell us what are the qualities that you
look for in a man um well there's of
course the obvious things like I want
him to be sweet and kind
I'm talking about the real things you're
looking for
ha no but the first thing I noticed in a
guy is his teeth his teeth I have a
fetish I have a fetish I've never heard
of some other to study no yeah I'd like
to have a great smile and really white
bright teeth I'm trying to smile that
shows all a lot of teeth okay
across his creepy
it's creepy right that's not good
[Applause]